The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So today, we'll
talk about cost estimation.
It's the first of the
modeling lectures.
We'll talk very briefly
about the role--
the different roles
that cost models
have in transit agencies.
And then we'll discuss
three types of--
three categories of cost models.
So all right, let's get into it.
So what are the roles?
How could cost models be used?
And to start, a cost model is
a model, a mathematical model
that takes some
variables and predicts
some costs for the agency.
It could be operational cost.
It could be fixed cost.
So how could these be used?
The first row is predicting
the cost change associated
with a service change.
So this is a very
traditional typical example.
So you might extend
the route as we
are thinking about in this
assignment, Route 1770A,
extending it.
And you might wonder, how much
will that cost to operate?
So you could use a cost
model in that situation.
Or maybe there's a wider
increase in service.
Maybe service is being
expanded from ending
at 2 AM to running 24 hours.
How much would that cost?
So these are the kinds of
questions, service changes
that you might want to
have an idea of how much
will it cost me.
So they are often concerned with
marginal or incremental costs,
especially in this application.
So if you expand service to
cover all night, for example,
you may not need that--
that change may not
trigger the need for
a new bus maintenance
facility, or some large
capital expenditure.
So we're talking here about
per-- incremental cost.
As I add buses, or
as I add bus hours,
or as I add driver hours,
how much extra do I pay?
You have different results
over different time periods.
This is important.
It doesn't cost the same to run
service off-peak or at night
as it does on-peak.
I will talk more about
that later in this lecture.
But having that in mind,
and having a cost model that
is sensitive to
time periods might
be very important to
get accurate estimates.
OK, so these models
can also be used
for routine performance
monitoring and service policy
triggers.
You might remember from
the short-term planning
lectures that there are some
processes where every bus
route might be reviewed.
And you might decide that
you need to add service
based on its performance.
Or you might decide
that a bus route
isn't meeting the requirements
to be financially sustainable.
So if you are considering
removing, dropping
service [INAUDIBLE],, how much
will you save by doing that?
All of those are
applications of bus mode.
OK, the second point
here is that you
can predict the cost
change associated
with the change in a
production process.
Now, we're not talking
so much about service,
but we're thinking
of, what happens
if I'm in a labor agreement
that does not allow part timers,
and now has negotiated the
ability to hire part timers?
What will that do to cost,
sort of cost structure?
What about if I want to
contract out maintenance work?
I'm doing that
right now in-house.
And now maybe for a
portion or for all of it,
we are looking at
public-private partnerships
to contract out
maintenance work.
Or contracting out suburban
bus routes-- for instance,
I have low ridership.
And they're kind of
on the outskirts.
You don't want to drop
service, but maybe you
don't need big 40-foot
buses and you can run them
with smaller buses.
Could you contract those out?
What will that do to cost?
New fare technology, the MBTA--
I don't know who was
here a long time ago.
We had tokens here.
And we moved to the CharlieCard.
And now the MBTA is thinking
about the next generation
of fare collection for Boston.
AUDIENCE: When was the
CharlieCard invented?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
I don't remember the year.
AUDIENCE: 2005.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
But it was--
yeah, it was the mid-2000s--
AUDIENCE: 2005.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
--because I remember in 2004
there being tokens still.
AUDIENCE: I think the
last station with tokens
was Government Center in 2006.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So anytime something
like this happens,
there is a change
in costs, administration costs.
And the recovery of the fare
recovery ratio might change.
So can we model that?
And can we use cost models
to predict those changes
in cost or in revenue?
OK, then another sort of third
and very important application,
not so much in Boston
right now, but certainly
in other jurisdictions,
is the allocation
of subsidy required
by jurisdiction.
So if you look at, for example,
the WMATA in Washington, DC,
there are different districts.
And they all have
to pay for service.
So there are many examples of
this over the states and also
internationally, where different
jurisdictions are essentially
partnering to subsidize
public transportation service.
And we know what the total
cost of operation is.
So how much is fair that
each restriction pay?
According to size, according
to how many people--
often, it's according
to how many people
ride from those jurisdictions.
So you might have a data
collection to figure out
how many people are taking buses
from each of the jurisdictions.
And then you need to allocate
a cost allocation model
to take all of the costs,
including the things that
are sort of more obvious, like
the bus hours that operate
in those jurisdictions, but also
things that are not directly
connected to the jurisdictions,
such as administration
costs, and facility
maintenance, and those things.
So all of that needs to be
allocated to each jurisdiction
so that the cost can be
evenly or fairly split.
And doing that right
is critical, often,
even for the decision
to participate or not
in this program.
Question?
AUDIENCE: For jurisdictions,
you mentioned Washington.
Would that be like
Virginia and Washington DC?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Or in New York,
it would be New York--
Port Authority of New
York and New Jersey?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Or would you
also mean, like, counties?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
There are many examples
and different structures of how
different jurisdictions come
together to provide service.
So in some cases, you have
many different operators,
and more commonly in
the West of the US,
many different operators all
providing service somehow.
In other cases, you have
one major operator funded
by different jurisdictions.
All right, so you
might remember,
we've only talked about
modal capacities and costs
that, especially in the
US, in North America,
costs are divided into capital
expenditures and operations
expenditures.
So capital costs have to do
with the purchase of vehicles,
or the [INAUDIBLE] of
vehicles, heavy maintenance,
the fixed facility
construction, so construction
or major repairs of
trucks, garage, stations,
bus stops, things
like that, and then
other long-term physical assets,
so administration buildings,
and things like that.
And then there's
operating costs.
So those have to do with--
they're more
proportional to how much
service you output, so labor
wages and benefits, materials
and supplies.
Materials includes fuel,
and tires, and electricity
to run the-- power the metro.
Then there's agency
administration and other kinds
of expenses of this nature.
So it's important to
keep those two in mind,
because the cost
models that we specify
should take this
into consideration
and be able to allocate
the capital and operating
expenses separately.
All right, so there are
three types of cost models
that we're going to discuss.
The first is a fully
allocated causal factor model.
It's the simplest of
ones that we'll discuss.
One of the problems
with that model
is that it allocates all of
the costs to some categories.
And it's not sensitive
to time periods.
As I said earlier, some costs
vary a lot by time period.
So the second model essentially
is a variation or an extension
of the first one, where we do
take some specific costs that
are very sensitive to
time and capture that,
those differences, over time.
And then we'll talk about
incremental fixed/variable cost
models.
We're going to give examples
of all of these using MBTA bus
from the '90s as an example.
Let's start with the first
one, the fully allocated
causal factor model.
So here's what you do.
You select some causal factors.
So these are not necessarily--
maybe causal factor is one
of the best term, but
that's what this model is--
class is called.
I would say, these are
explanatory variables more
than causal factors.
They don't have to
cause the cost directly,
but they are used as explanatory
variables in a model of cost.
So then you assign each expense
type to each of the factors.
So for example, operator
wages and benefits,
where would that go?
If you were thinking of three
kinds of explanatory variables,
vehicle hours being one,
vehicle miles being the second,
and peak vehicles
being the third,
and you're going to assign
every cost you incur
to one of those three, then
operator wages and benefits
are more appropriately
assigned to vehicle hours,
because the pay
drivers by the hour,
so this is the one that it
relates to most closely.
Fuel-- so fuel may be a
combination of vehicle hours
and vehicle miles.
Or if you have to assign them
to one, then vehicle miles--
you think of the fuel
mileage of vehicles.
So that's the one
that most closely
relates vehicle miles to fuel.
And then administration--
well, administration, you
might want to assign
it to peak vehicles,
because peak vehicles is a proxy
for how big is this agency.
And the bigger that agency,
the bigger the administration
costs.
So it's one way of
assigning these things.
So this is an example.
After you do all
those assignments,
you calculate the average
costs for each of the factors.
So you have, for
example, the cost
assigned to vehicle hours
divided by the total number
of vehicle hours.
And you have those unit costs.
And then the cost
model is simply
each of those unit
costs divided--
or multiplied by the three
explanatory variables
that you included.
So you multiply your
unit vehicle hour cost
by the number of vehicle
hours, your unit vehicle miles
cost by vehicle miles,
and your unit peak
vehicles cost by peak vehicles.
And that is the total
cost of the agency.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: This assumes
that you're somehow
able to split the data
into those categories,
to say the costs assigned
to vehicle hours are x.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yes, so that's one
of the characteristics and
perhaps weaknesses of this kind
of model, that it requires
the judgment of the person
to assign--
to first, to generate
these classes
and these explanatory
variables, and second,
to assign them to each
cost of this class or each
account in a ledger to each of
these explanatory variables.
So But these models are
used in the industry.
So if you plug in the
number of vehicle hours,
and vehicle miles,
and peak vehicles
that you used to
estimate this model,
then you're just going
to get the total cost
of operations or of--
or total combined cost
on the same period
that this data came from.
But more interestingly,
if you are considering
expanding service, and that will
increase vehicle hours, vehicle
miles, and peak
vehicles, then this model
will work in some
ways to forecast
what the total cost will be
after you grow your agency.
So this is one application
of this simple model.
AUDIENCE: Is there a time unit
that you're supposed to use,
like a full year to
capture [INAUDIBLE]??
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
This is up to you
as well, another judgment call.
It shouldn't be one day, but--
because you want to see
all the kinds of expenses.
So I think a year makes
sense, a fiscal year,
because you will have to put
out a statement for [INAUDIBLE]..
You do accounting on
that fiscal year basis.
OK, so here's an example from
1996 of a bus on the MBTA.
So we have those three
variables that we
talked about--
vehicle hours, vehicle
miles, and peak vehicles.
We divide each of those
into variable or fixed.
So some of the expenses
are considered variable,
because they sort of scale up
more linearly as you increase
the number of vehicle hours.
And others are more
fixed expenses.
You wouldn't expect to
get extra fixed costs
by adding a few buses, right?
So one example of
that is, if you
get 10 more buses
for a new bus route,
you don't need a new
maintenance facility.
So your maintenance
facility might
be considered a fixed expense.
And you might want a
variable cost model
to predict the changes
of that small change
or that marginal change.
So that's why we divide things
into fixed and variable.
The total cost to be
allocated is $173.6 million.
And we divide it over these
six categories, so the three
variables and their fixed
and variable variance.
Here we have the percentages
of each and the unit costs.
So now, what are possible cost
models following this approach?
A first and simple one,
a very traditional model,
is the first one listed here.
So 39.82, which is the total
unit cost of revenue vehicle
hours-- it's the sum
of 37.13 and 2.69--
times the number of revenue
vehicle hours, and then 2.41,
which is the sum of 2.270 and
0.14 times revenue vehicle
miles times some factor.
And that factor,
essentially here, we have--
we're not capturing
the difference
between fixed and
variable costs.
So that's why we add them
up here, 39.82 and 2.41.
The other characteristic
of this model
is that it does not
have peak vehicles
as an explanatory variable.
So we address that with
this adjustment factor.
If you take the total
cost, which is 173.6,
and you divide it by the sum
of the unit costs for revenue
vehicle hours and revenue
vehicle miles, you get 1.26.
And that's the
adjustment factor.
So any questions--
AUDIENCE: Sorry--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
--with that approach?
AUDIENCE: You said the 1.26
is calculated by doing what?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Let me write it down for you.
So you have a total of 173.6.
And that's a total.
And you divide it by the total
of the total number of unit
costs that you are capturing
with explanatory variables,
which is 29 plus 5.7 plus 50--
AUDIENCE: Plus 3.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
--plus 3.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: And last [INAUDIBLE]--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
--equals 1.261.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So we're
dividing the total by the
amount that we did capture.
And then that factors
out of the model.
So this is a very simple
model of a full annual cost
for the agency.
Here we're looking
at the fiscal year.
And it's sensitive
to two variables.
It's not sensitive
to time period.
And it's mixing fixed
and variable costs.
So this model may not be the
best one for some applications.
AUDIENCE: But just,
what's the intuition
behind using vehicle
hours and vehicle miles?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
It's something that you--
that agencies always
measure and report,
so it's something that there's
already a data collection
effort for it.
If you think about especially
the traditional applications
without automatic
data collection,
there is an effort
to measure anything
you deliver to collect how
much output you produce.
And so we already have that.
It's something that then you can
use as an explanatory variable.
And it relates to service.
So it's your service output.
These are variables
that are also
going to be found in any
service funding proposal
in some way or another.
If you extend routes, then
that increases both of these.
AUDIENCE: I guess my
other question was, like,
what's the intuition behind
vehicle hours being relatively
more expensive
than vehicle miles?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
That depends
on how you assign each of
these cost categories to it.
AUDIENCE: It's not that, like,
operating a bus implies--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Well, I mean, in this case,
wages are--
wages and benefits are a
principle or one of the key--
AUDIENCE: Got it, OK.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
--one of the key costs
for the agency.
And that's being reflected
entirely in vehicle hours.
And potentially fuel
is a second one.
And that is at least
partially covered
by running vehicle hours.
It could be.
I'm not sure in
this model if it is.
I suspect that everything was
assigned to vehicle miles,
but it could be.
So yeah, vehicle hours is
a proxy for more things.
More costs are being
assigned to that variable.
Eli?
AUDIENCE: Can you
give some examples
of variable and fixed costs?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yeah, we'll
actually see more of those
later in the lecture.
Fuel is variable,
because as you drive more
and you consume more--
and if you all of a sudden
operate less
service, then you'll
see that drop immediately.
A fixed cost could be
the administration costs
for, let's say, your
service planner team.
So you've hired people.
And if you drop
service a little bit,
you're not necessarily
going to fire people.
Or if you expand service,
you're not necessarily
going to hire a bunch of people.
Or you may not need
new offices for them.
So all of those
things are more fixed.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
OK, second model, so here we
have the same first
part of the model,
but now, instead of using
the adjustment factor,
we directly take the unit cost
of peak vehicles and add it in.
So now we have a model that
is sensitive to peak vehicles
as well.
And we don't need
the adjustment,
because all of the things
that have been assigned
to peak vehicles are
being directly related
to peak vehicles.
So it's a simple variation.
And here, we have a
variable annual cost model.
So these first two have all of
the costs, fixed and variable.
But for some
applications, you're
only interested in
variable annual cost.
And I've given the
example of minor expansion
in service, where you add
a little bit of service
or remove a little
bit of service.
And you wouldn't expect to
incur fixed costs as a result.
So here, we then only
consider the unit costs
of the variable portion of
revenue vehicle hours, which
is 37.13, and 2.57 for
revenue vehicle miles.
Any questions on
these simple models?
OK, as I mentioned before,
one of the key weaknesses
of these models is that they're
not sensitive to time periods.
So it's much more expensive
to operate sort of on the peak
than it is off-peak.
So if you were to use, say,
variable annual cost model
for bus routes 70
and 78 and now you
want to expand it
to go to Kendall,
or Lechmere, or somewhere else,
and you have a greater number
of revenue vehicle hours than
your revenue vehicle miles,
if you-- maybe if
you expand service
proportionally throughout the
peak and off-peak, you're fine.
But if you only expand
service in the peak or do it
disproportionately
peak/off-peak,
then this model will not capture
those differences very well.
And for that, we need
temporal variational,
which is our next--
AUDIENCE: Just a second, but
why wouldn't you capture it?
Because suppose I had service.
Suppose I had a bus in the peak.
So now peak vehicles,
that gets impacted.
But suppose I take fuel and
I say, OK, there is fuel.
Fuel affects revenue miles, but
also it affects revenue hours.
And I put fuel in twice, both
in the hours and the miles.
Now I can also take
into account the fact
that the bus is sitting in
traffic and burning fuel
and also--
but I'm taking
that into account.
So why is this model
necessarily [INAUDIBLE]..
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So the questions
why does this model
not adequately capture
peak versus off-peak costs?
So it goes back to this
calculating average costs
by factor.
So these are averages.
You're taking averages of
all the vehicles at all times
of day and dividing by--
explaining them with
an explanatory variable
that is not necessarily
was directly causing it.
And so especially driver costs
are going to vary a lot by sort
of peak/off-peak.
And we're taking an average.
So if you increase service
proportionately, you're fine.
But the unit cost is not
reflecting the difference
between peak and off-peak.
So it's the unit
cost itself more than
the independent variable
that you put in,
which is what you're saying.
You're saying, I can measure the
independent variable precisely,
so I can plug it in here.
Well, but your
factor is average.
AUDIENCE: I see.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So the approach
of this model, which is an
extension of the first one,
is to do everything that we
did except for driver costs,
because these costs are very
sensitive to time of day.
And for those costs, per
crew costs, we take the day.
We divide it into
30-minute periods.
And then we look at all runs.
Now, a run is what a
driver does in a day.
That's their shift.
That's a sequence of
trips that are being
operated by a single driver.
And we look at all
runs and all periods.
And for each period, any
run that is at least this--
has at least 15
minutes in that period
gets included in that period.
And then we compute the
average paid per vehicle hour
by dividing the daily pay by
the number of vehicle hours
over all runs in that period.
So each of these runs is going
to have a different cost.
Some runs are going to
operate more in the peak.
And they're going to have
more overtime, for example,
or more spread penalties.
And we'll talk about those now.
And so those runs will
be more expensive.
Other runs that are straight
are going to be less expensive.
And you can calculate
an average for each 30-
or 50-minute period.
So now we have an
average again, but it's
by time of day for a
small bucket of time.
And then for each of those, we
find the minimum, the average,
and the maximum.
So we're not only going
to look at averages.
We're going to also look at
the distribution of costs
along each period.
And this is just an
equation for average.
So what we have here
is the sum over all
runs in a specific period.
This is the wage, the total
paid for that run, divided
by the number of
hours for that run.
So we compute the average.
OK, if we look at the driver
requirements for the MBTA back
in 1983, the early 1980s,
this is what we get.
So many more
drivers are required
in the AM peak and the PM peak
than are required off-peak,
or early in the morning, or late
in the afternoon and evening.
Why is that?
We've talked a little
bit about it already.
AUDIENCE: There's more service.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So you provide more service.
Why do you need to
provide more service?
AUDIENCE: Because
that's when the--
AUDIENCE: More demand.
AUDIENCE: --commuters
are moving.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Because there's
more demand for it, right?
So if provided the
same level of service,
then your buses
would be too crowded
and you would not
deliver enough capacity.
What else?
AUDIENCE: They're
also in traffic more.
So buses are out--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So every trip
that you run takes longer,
and stuck in traffic.
And the dwell times are longer.
OK, so if you need
more, if you need
to provide more frequent service
and each run that you do,
each trip that
you run is slower,
than that means that
you have a greater cycle
time and a greater
frequency, and therefore,
a greater vehicle requirement
from your first assignment.
And of course you need drivers
the drive those vehicles,
so your driver
requirement also goes up.
Great, so what's
wrong with the time?
What's inconvenient about
the timing of the peaks?
AUDIENCE: They're
eight hours apart.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
They are eight hours apart.
And how long are
shifts typically?
AUDIENCE: Eight hours.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Eight hours long,
so if we hire someone to
start their shift at 6:00 AM,
they can't cover the PM peaks.
They only cover the AM peak.
OK, so what do we do?
One option is to
hire part timers.
So use full-time
employees for the base.
And then hire part
timers for the peaks.
That's the least expensive
and most efficient option.
But unions don't like
it, because if you
have a high percentage of
part-time drivers, then
it's not to the benefit
of their union employees.
If you don't allow
part timers or you
cap the allowance
on part timers,
then the agency is required
to hire full-time employees
to cover the AM and the PM peak.
And if you only do
that, then that's
terribly inefficient, because
you're hiring for eight hours.
Then you can only
operate two or three.
That's all that you
need that driver for.
But there is some arrangement.
You can actually
have shifts that
have a break in the
middle of the day.
And these are called
spread shifts.
So some of these shifts
operate for two or three
hours in the morning, have
a long break during the day,
and operate for two or three
hours in the afternoon.
And often, these shifts
are paid a spread penalty.
So in this example, what
we have in white here
are shifts that last between
10 hours and 11 hours.
So the spread is the difference
between the check-out time
and the check-in time.
And shifts in white here have a
spread between 10 and 11 hours.
Those drivers are paid a
50% premium for any hours
above 8 hours.
And then there are
these other shifts that
are between 11 and 13 hours.
So 11, 12 in dark
gray, and 12 and 13
shaded diagonally, these
shifts are paid 100%.
So they're paid double for
any hours in excess of the--
I guess in excess
of 11, in this case.
So that's going
to drive costs up,
because if you look at the
total pay for that shift
over the day, then the
unit pay per hour for each
of those drivers is higher.
And if you look at any
time slice of the day,
peaks are going to have
many more of those drivers
than off-peak.
So the average across the
drivers on any bucket of time
that is 30 minutes wide
is going to be higher.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, could you
explain maybe for like,
let's say I'm a driver that
runs the shifts with 12 hours
less than spread, 13
hours, the bottom one.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
This one, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] they're
driving, the peak ones--
like, when would I work and
what hours do I get paid for?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Excellent segue
for the next slide.
So here we have essentially
the runs by a driver.
And you can see the--
if you draw a line here,
this is 8:00 AM, so AM peak.
And then this is 5:00
PM right around here.
So you see that, if you draw a
line between 8:00 and 5:00 PM,
these are the shifts that
start during the AM peak.
And those shifts have
the biggest spreads.
So any one of these rows
is an example of one run.
And if you could be
one of these drivers--
so if you have this day,
you check in at 6:30.
You have a pretty long
break during the day.
And you check out at
8:00-- at 6:00 PM.
So you do an hour in the PM.
And you can have
longer ones too.
There will be some rules that
prevent excessively long ones.
AUDIENCE: And when
you were saying
I get paid 50% more
as that bus driver, do
I get paid 50% more for the--
only the hours that I'm working?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK, got it.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: And
that will vary by agreement.
So that's specific to
this labor agreement.
AUDIENCE: And during
in between the shifts?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: So
you are paid the spread penalty.
And you are paid--
there are a bunch
of rules. like,
No matter how many hours
you work, you're paid
a minimum of eight.
There's a swing pay bonus.
So if you start your
day somewhere different
than you end the day, then
you have to pay the person,
I think, 30 minutes extra
for their driving time,
or whatever, for getting
to the other location
where you potentially
left your car.
So there are compensations
for all of these things.
And the point here in
this cost modeling lecture
is that these drivers with
spread, with large spreads,
cost more.
So we want to build
a cost model that
recognizes those
differences, especially
with regards to driver hours.
So we extend service and
require more driver hours
more in the peak
than in the off-peak.
Then we need to account
for those differences.
Here is a graph by time of day
of the wage cost per platform
hour, just by hour, divided
by the base pay rate.
So off-peak, you see that the
average is variables to one.
But if you go to the
peak, then you're
paying an average
of, say, 25% higher,
because some of the drivers
are straight shifts,
but there's a mix
of drivers that
are spread, large spread,
and being paid some spread
penalties.
So that drives the costs up.
OK, here's an exercise
to solidify this concept.
Oh, before that we
have a question.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, is it uncommon
that the employees, they night
[INAUDIBLE] price.
I mean that someone
starts working at night
and drives some buses or trains.
And they go to sleep,
and after the day,
restart their work
in the morning?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So for safety reasons,
a lot of labor
agreements require--
and any work rules
require a minimum amount
of break between
the end of a run
and the start of the next one.
And that could be 12 hours.
So you know, where that
person sleeps is up to them.
I suppose most of them go home.
Normally the rules
won't allow you
to have a run that, if
you end service at 5:00,
you won't be able to
check in at 8:00 again.
If you did a full day
that end at 5:00 AM,
you're probably not
going to be allowed
to start the next
full day at 8:00 AM,
because that's not
a long enough break.
And that would be unsafe.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I said
this because in Japan,
it is very common to have some
place to stay and provide them.
And also it enable us to
run the very late night
[INAUDIBLE] services.
So yeah, I'm just
curious about this.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
I didn't know about that.
I'm interested to
learn more about it.
AUDIENCE: Would people
want to do that every day?
Or would they, like, maybe
expect to do that once a week?
AUDIENCE: It depends
on the shift,
but no one continue
that kind of--
AUDIENCE: Yeah you'd--
AUDIENCE: --shift.
AUDIENCE: --live at work.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, what?
AUDIENCE: You would just live
at work and do your whole life
just not doing anything else.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
I mean, these
are maybe cultural
differences for work rules
differences across cultures.
I'd love to learn more about it.
If you have any reference
that you can send me,
that would be great.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Any other questions?
Ari, I think you had a question.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I was going to
say that based on Chicago, which
runs overnight service,
there is so few enough shifts
that, basically,
everything is [INAUDIBLE]
as a straight shift.
But I think when you bid
for an overnight shift,
you basically get
all overnight shifts.
You keep on that
rhythm so you wouldn't
have an overnight and a day.
And there are some operators
that really like the overnight
shift, because it provides--
they can care for kids during
the day, or just
they like that--
like working outside the peaks.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: I
don't know what the labor rules
are there, but some, personally,
they also get a premium
for taking the--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
There are usually
premiums for running on holidays
or running late at night.
So the least desirable runs
might have an extra premium
associated to compensate
for the inconvenience
or the undesirability thereof.
Great, so we have
an example here
where we've done this
exercise and we've looked
at all periods of the day.
We've looked at the minimum, the
average, and the maximum unit
costs for drivers, so
screw, for peak, off-peak,
and the combination
of peak and off-peak.
And we have six
different scenarios.
And we want to choose the
unit cost for each of these.
So let's go one by one.
So what happens if we
want to increase the peak
and off-peak service
proportionally?
Which unit cost from this
matrix would you use?
AUDIENCE: Combined.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So we're hearing combined--
agreement, yeah?
And from combining, would
you take minimum, average,
or maximum?
AUDIENCE: Average.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Average combined?
Yeah, OK, and why is that?
Because it's proportional
on both ends.
And we don't actually need
the temporal variation model
for this.
So we can go without.
What if it's a proportional
decrease in both peak
and off-peak?
Would we use the same one?
AUDIENCE: Minimum combined?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Some
people are saying the same one.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
You're saying minimum combined.
We have one minimum combined.
What's your idea for
minimum combined?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Retracting, OK.
AUDIENCE: When you say
minimum cost or average cost,
is that for the peak period
or is that for [INAUDIBLE]??
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So if it's peak,
it will be for the peak hours.
If it's off-peak, it's
for off-pea, hours.
AUDIENCE: No, I mean the--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: But
minimum maximum hours, like,
within the peak hours, then
there are some drivers that are
paid more on average and
others that are paid less,
because some of them are--
have spread penalties,
and others don't.
So even in the peaks,
are straight shifts.
And those are on the low end.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Well, I
guess, wouldn't you
want to use-- like, if were
going to add to the peak,
is it a bad assumption
to assume that it's
going to be more expensive
than your most [INAUDIBLE]??
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
We're getting to that.
So the third one is, increases
in peak period services only,
so--
AUDIENCE: But I
guess, even combined,
like, wouldn't you want
to use the max or the min
because it's incremental?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
The idea
is that, if you increase
things proportionally, then
you're going to have the
same mix that you have
now but a little more each.
If you add service both peak and
off-peak in proportion, which
means that, if there is twice
as much peak service, then
you're going to have twice
much more peak service,
then you're going to have the
same distribution of spread
penalties, and therefore,
the same average costs.
But now we go to the
next question, which
is, increases in peak period
services only, which of these
would you use?
AUDIENCE: The max.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
We're hearing max.
And I assume for
peak, max for peak?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Any other ideas?
AUDIENCE: Peak average.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Peak average, two ideas--
OK, let's debate.
AUDIENCE: All
right, so basically,
if we're increasing in
the peak period only,
we're going to have to do
more of these spread shifts
to do that.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And those are
our most expensive shifts.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yes, are you convinced?
AUDIENCE: I'm convinced.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: OK,
good so great, so $45 right,
the maximum of the peak--
what if it's a decrease
in peak period service?
So now we're coming
back here and we're only
taking the top of the top off
and we're not giving anything
to the off-peak [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: The inverse.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Same, 45--
AUDIENCE: Maximum
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
--going down now, OK, great--
OK, increases in off-peak
period services only,
so now we're leaving
the peak where it is.
And we're decreasing service
off-peak-- so here and maybe
at night.
AUDIENCE: Increasing, you said?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Decreasing--
is it decreasing or increasing?
AUDIENCE: Increase.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Let's start with increasing.
AUDIENCE: Then maybe
minimum in off-peak?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
OK, that's
actually the high end
of what it could be.
So of the cells
here, yes, that's
the one that you should pick.
You should use the
minimum off-peak.
But it could actually
be closer to 0.
If you're depending on the
cost structure and the spread
penalties, you will
be able to convert
some of the drivers that
are peak to spread--
to a non-spread shift.
So you'll get straight
shifts from these drivers.
And that may actually
compensate so much
that it's a free conversion.
So what about decreases in
off-peak period service?
So now we are actually
decreasing the off-peak
and leaving everything the same.
So what two things happen?
Presumably, off-peak
services are straight runs.
They're not spread.
So if you remove those
but keep the peak level
operation the same, then for
any of those that you remove,
you have to--
AUDIENCE: Add in
the most expensive--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: --add
in the most expensive ones.
So what is the net effect?
AUDIENCE: Adding $15.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
It's probably
going to be close to 0 again
because of this effect.
AUDIENCE: But can you explain--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
And again, this
depends on the specific
costs for the labor agreement
and the spread penalties
and everything.
But it gives you an idea.
So if you only decrease
off-peak service--
AUDIENCE: You're
getting rid of those.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
--then you have to remove a few
of the straight runs and
not pay them the full day,
but you have to then get--
you have to convert some of
the existing spread runs to--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] straight.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
--from straight to spread.
AUDIENCE: Well wait, why
is it at a cost of 0 then?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Because you--
even though you are reducing
the number of driver hours,
you will increase the proportion
of the most expensive ones
only in the peak.
AUDIENCE: So you might not
wind up saving any money.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Exactly.
AUDIENCE: Where would
you put it in the matrix?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Well, it's not in the matrix.
But if anything, you would
look at off-peak minimum.
But it's going to be in
the range of 0 to 30.
And again, depending on
the specific numbers,
it could even be that
you have to pay more.
Or many things can happen.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: --thinking it was
going to be like the occupant
minimum and the peak maximum.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yeah, it could be.
That's a good idea.
But again, it depends
on the specifics.
And this is a cost model
that isn't so precise.
AUDIENCE: You're saying,
because you're not actually
increasing peak service,
but you're proportionally
increasing it.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Not proportionally, we're
just decreasing the off-peak
and not touching the peak.
AUDIENCE: OK, but then, I
mean, proportionally, more
of your hours are on the peak.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yes, exactly.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Exactly, yeah.
All right--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So that was a good.
There's a mistake in this slide.
Please fix it.
It says here, "see page 8."
It should be, "see page 6."
OK, so from page six, the total
fixed cost to be allocated
is $44.6 million.
And that is the sum of--
we want to allocate fixed costs.
So that is the sum
of all the fixed
costs that appear on page six.
There's 5.7, 3, and 35.9.
That adds up to 44.6.
And now we have here number of
buses operating on the peak,
on the base, on the
evening, Saturday
and Sunday, the
number of hours--
so peak average,
4.5, 6 base hours,
4 evening hours for a total
of 14.5 hours per week day,
12 hours operating Saturday,
12 hours operating Sunday.
And the objective
of this model is
to take the fixed costs
incurred by the agency
and allocate them
to vehicle hours.
So let's do that.
We have to do this allocation.
And we can start with--
one way of looking at this
is, these evening buses,
250 evening buses are
also operating in the base
and in the peak.
Then there's an
additional 125 buses
that are operating only in
the base and at Saturdays,
during Saturdays.
And then there's an
additional 400 buses
that are operating only in
the peak during the weekday.
So let's allocate costs to
the 250, the additional 125,
and the additional 400 according
to how long they operate
and how much it costs
based on the unit costs
that we calculated
in this example.
So we start with 250 buses
across all time periods.
What's the share of fixed
cost to be allocated to them?
It's 32%.
It's 250 buses divided
by the total number
of buses, which is 775.
That's 32%.
32% of the total cost
is $14.4 million.
That's how much money we want
to allocate to these buses.
And how many bus hours are
operated in the whole year?
Well, there's 250 buses.
And we want to add
up the hours operated
during weekdays, during
Saturdays, and during Sundays
for the whole week.
So there are
roughly 250 weekdays
in a year, 58 Saturdays,
and 57 Sundays.
Those add up to 365 days.
And there are 14.5
hours during the weekday
and 12 on the weekends.
So we add those up.
We multiply by the
number of buses.
And we get 1.25 million bus
hours for the whole year.
And if we divide
the $14.4 million
by 1.25 million bus hours,
we get an average cost
per bus hour of $11.52.
And that's the base, which is
the only thing that applies
in the evening and Sundays.
And it is a portion
of what applies
in Saturday, weekday days,
and peak, so only a portion.
So now let's move to
the next 125 buses
operating on all time periods
except Sundays and weekday
evenings.
So how much money do
we have to allocate?
The $44.6 million total divided
by the additional 125 buses
divided by the total
number of buses.
That's $7.2 million.
How many total bus hours are
operated by those 125 buses?
Well, this is 10.5
hours excluding
the evening during the weekdays
times 250 weekdays plus the 12
hours on Saturdays
times the 58 Saturdays.
So that's 0.42
million bus hours.
And 7.2 divided by 0.42
is $17.14 average cost
per bus hour.
Do you follow?
Any questions on this?
OK, now let's do the peak.
That's the most expensive part.
So how much do we
have to allocate?
It's $23 million.
How do we get that?
44.6 total times
400 divided by 725.
And how many annual bus
hours do we need to--
do we operate during the peak?
It's 400 additional buses only
in the peak times 4.5 hours
of the peak times 250 weekdays.
And that's 0.45 million hours.
And 23 million by 0.45
is $51.11 average cost
per bus hour, or per peak
bus hour, in this case.
OK, so now we have unit
costs for peak, for the base,
and then the off-peak, for
the evenings' and Sundays'
operation, which is great.
So the variable vehicle
cost was $37.13.
We had calculated that
from the previous model
that you can find on page six.
And now we can
adjust these costs
by time period, which
is what we want to do.
We want to have a model that
is sensitive to time periods.
So for Sunday evening service,
we will increase the $37.13
by $11.52.
For Saturday and
weekday service,
we want to increase the cost,
the base cost of $37.13,
by $13.97.
And for weekday peak, we want
to increase it by $32.86.
And notice that when we look
at Saturday and weekday,
we have to combine
the two unit costs,
because we have a
portion of Saturday
and weekday-based service
is from the first 375 buses.
And the portion of it is from
the additional more expensive
125 buses.
And when we do peak,
the same thing applies.
So we start with the 250
base buses at $11.52.
Then we have 125 at $17.14.
And then we have the peak
of the peak buses, which
are 400 times the unit
cost for those buses, which
is much higher.
And that's the total
cost, the total unit cost
for a weekday peak service.
Questions on this?
You have a question, Eli?
This is all sort
of written here.
And all the numbers are
copied from previous slides,
so you should be able to
follow this on your own
if you're a little lost.
But if not, come
see me after class,
then we can talk about it.
OK, so now let's
compare the models.
We started out with a very
traditional simple model,
and the first one we gave,
which was full annual cost.
And it had this factor
which accounted for the fact
that we weren't including
the peak vehicle, the costs
associated with peak vehicles.
So that was the first example.
We also had in that page a
variable cost model, which
only accounts for
variable costs,
so it excludes fixed costs.
And now we can look at
the peak period model
and off-peak period model.
So we make an adjustment
to the first model, which--
to this variable cost
model with the unit
cost that we just calculated.
So if we take the $37.13
of revenue vehicle hours
that was in our initial
variable cost model
and we add the unit cost
for peak revenue hours,
which is $32.86
from right here--
so that's the weekday
peak service unit cost--
then we get $69.99.
Now that becomes our
unit cost in the peak.
And we have the 2.41.
Give me a second here.
That comes from page
six directly, I believe.
Yes, so that's the
combination of 2.27 and 0.14.
Because we're not counting
the temporal difference
on peak vehicle or
revenue vehicle miles.
We're only doing it for
revenue vehicle hours.
It's for driver cost.
And driver costs were associated
with hours, not miles.
So that stays the same.
So this is our full
annual peak cost model.
And if we want to increase
peak-only service,
we use this model,
not the other one.
And it will reflect
more faithfully
what the costs will be.
We can do the same
with off-peak service.
So we take the $37.13.
And we can add the combination
of the portion of it
that is $11.52 and the
portion of it that is $13.97.
Let's do that.
So let me have--
let's do that on the board
so that we have the example.
So for off-peak period
model, we start out
with the base cost of $37.13.
And then we add $11.52.
And that's going to apply
only for the fraction
of off-peak hours that are sort
of Sunday and weekday evening.
So if we go back to $11.52, this
is Sunday and evening service
only.
So the question is, how many
Sunday and evening service
hours are there in a whole year?
The proportion is this
one that I'm writing here,
1684 divided by 3,880.
And I'll calculate
that too in a second.
We also want to add the
other cost, which is $13.97.
And the proportion of that
is 2,196 divide by 3,880.
So that's 37.13 plus
about 5 plus about 7.91.
And that comes out to 50.04.
OK, so where do we get
1,684 and 2,196 from?
It's similar to before, right?
We just count how
many hours there are.
So let's just do it quickly
here for the record.
So let's just compute
the bottom one, actually.
And you'll get the
idea for the others,
because it doesn't make
sense to do all of them.
So off peak hours--
so we have 10 off-peak hours in
the weekday times 250 weekdays
per year plus--
so this is weekdays--
plus 12 hours on Saturdays.
And we said there are 7--
or 58 Saturdays per year--
plus 12 hours on Sundays, and
we said 57 Sundays per year.
And that comes out
to 3,880 hours.
So that's combinations of these
to get the 1,684 and the 2,196.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So for
the 1,684, that's
Sunday evening service, right?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Right, so yes, exactly.
So that's Sunday
and evenings, right.
AUDIENCE: And then the other
is Saturday and weekend base?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yes, exactly.
So did people follow
this allocation example?
So what we're doing is taking--
dividing the day into periods.
Some periods, we recognize
are more expensive than others
throughout.
Now, we have fixed cost.
And we want to allocate
them across periods.
more cost to the peak,
because that sort of costs more.
So we then use these
unit costs to--
and we count how many
hours we provide off-peak
and during the peak.
And we do things in proportions
to that, essentially.
These are not the
only cost models
that you can come up with.
These are not the only
ways of allocating cost.
But they provide an
example of how you
can go about allocating costs.
Allocating cost is a science.
It's also an art.
And you encounter
it in agencies,
because you have these huge
budgets, and huge expenditures.
And many projects require
you to allocate to a portion
or allocate costs.
And if you want to have a
cost model, you have to do it,
because your cost
model should reflect
these different variables,
explanatory variables.
The third and last type of model
that we are going to discuss
is the incremental
fixed variable model.
It's somewhat similar to
the ones that we saw before,
but now we classify costs as
being variable, semi-variable,
and fixed.
So we have a little more
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
--precision--
AUDIENCE: ----[INAUDIBLE]
marked by--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: --a
little more precision in how--
in what we consider
fixed or variable.
We also have the same
explanatory variables
that we had before, so
vehicle hours, vehicle miles,
and peak vehicles.
So now, the combination
of these are
nine different
explanatory variables.
And we do the same thing
as we have done before.
We have a schedule of expenses.
These are our accounts
in your ledger,
so crew wages, vehicle
servicing, fuel, tires,
insurance, traffic stuff,
things like publicity, and rent,
and building maintenance.
Everything is included here.
So all of your budget is going
to fall into some category.
It's divided among
these categories.
So now you decide,
for each of these,
which of these three
resources apply
and which cost type you
consider this to be.
So for example, crew
wages, let's associate
that with bus hours,
as we did before.
And that's fully variable.
So that, we should
feel comfortable with.
Things like building utilities,
that shouldn't be variable.
So that's a fixed cost.
And we'll associate
that with peak buses,
because peak buses
is the one that we
say is a good proxy for
how big the agency is.
So peak buses is, again, like
agency size, if you will.
So then there are
things in the middle.
So publicity, well,
semi-variable, because if you--
so the extent that
you increase service,
there is going to be some
amount of additional publicity.
It's not going to be
necessarily a linear proportion
increase with as you-- you
know, we add one more bus,
then you have that much more
marketing or publicity expense.
Some of those expenses are
having an office and staff, so
some salaries, so
that portion is fixed.
But then there is
extra space that you
have to cover on each additional
bus, so that part is variable.
So now we have a
semi-variable cost.
And you can associate that,
in this case, with peak buses,
because for each peak
bus you have, then
that's how many buses you
have to plaster with ads.
That gives you an example.
So you can go through
each of these.
Again, this requires judgment,
and therefore, each person
may do it slightly differently.
But you use a schedule.
And you then build your--
you calculate your unit
costs, much like we
did with the earlier examples.
And you then apply the model.
But now we have more precision.
So if you have some
kind of new expense,
or you decide you're going
to save some money somehow,
then you decide,
what-- how am I going
to spend less or spend more?
Would that be a variable,
semi-variable, or fixed cost?
Would I associate that with
vehicle hours, vehicle miles,
or peak vehicles?
And then you would
use that unit cost
to bring the total costs
up or down from the agency.
Even more detailed
models, you could just
go by expense category and do
your engineering-style sort
of budget if you want
to really calculate
exactly how much
cost you'll save,
or exactly how much
extra cost you'll incur.
But these cost models
are applied more--
a little more
bluntly in projects
where you are
evaluating, especially
at an early stage,
what it would cost.
And you have
different scenarios.
And you want to quickly
know how much it would cost.
OK, so questions
on cost modeling?
No questions on cost--
yeah, one question?
AUDIENCE: So in this case, you
would have more reliability
on the proportion of
each expense assigned
to each category?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yeah, so you--
essentially, you're lumping
things a little less.
You have more variables.
So your unit costs
are more precise.
And I think the ability to move
to more sophisticated models
is increasing now that
everything is computer-based.
[INAUDIBLE], you had a question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Oh, the three of you
had a question.
No, not you?
OK.
AUDIENCE: I had a question.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
OK, Ethan.
AUDIENCE: Back on
Slide 11, you said
it's possible that
reducing driver
hours in off-peak periods
might have no effect
or could even potentially
actually increase costs.
AUDIENCE: It could-- well,
yeah, it shouldn't increase.
It shouldn't increase costs.
AUDIENCE: Well, I was
going to ask, is there--
is it ever the case that
off-peak service, when
there is really low
demand, exists simply
for the convenience of
scheduling shifts rather
than meeting maximum headways,
or anything like that?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Potentially,
but because driver costs are
not the only cost of operating
service, you would then also
agree to spend extra fuel
and extra maintenance costs.
And that is also a
significant portion of a cost.
It's not just free.
Or it's only-- only
this part may be free,
not the whole thing.
But yeah, I think, if you
find yourself in a situation
where your labor agreement
requires you to have--
maybe there is a cap on how
much spread you can have.
So you have all
these straight runs.
And they're only
working for four hours.
And then you say, well, you
know, let's add service.
And let's make the
off-peak service very good.
So yeah, that could happen,
but it's a management decision.
That's not something
with the science.
It's a policy
managerial decision.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: On the last slide
when you were talking about peak
buses, if we're
decreasing [INAUDIBLE],,
is it indicative of agency size?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yes.
So in this example,
we only have three--
well, we have nine
exploratory variables,
which are the combination of
the three resource variables
and the three cost types.
But if you go back to the
first example in this lecture,
we had three explanatory
variables-- bus hours,
bus miles, and peak buses.
And we have to assign everything
to one of these three.
So of those three,
peak buses is something
that most closely relates to how
large your agency is, much more
so than bus hours or bus miles.
And if you had other
variables, then
maybe those would be even
closer to agency size.
But in this example, we
only have these three--
yeah.
And why peak buses?
Well, because if
you have more buses,
you need a bigger
parking garage for them.
You need a bigger refueling
and maintenance facility.
You might need more
mechanics and more-- right?
So the many costs
that are mostly
fixed scale up with
how many vehicles
you have on your garage,
and how many garages you
have, and all those things.
Another detail which
I want to emphasize
is that, with regards
to the variable
and fixed, so again, if you
have to incur an expense that
is more marginal, then you might
want to use a variable cost
model, because you may not need
another garage, for example,
for a few extra buses.
But at some point,
you do incur on--
you reach an investment
threshold, where, well,
now you've crossed the line.
And you do need
an extra facility.
And you have to hire
people to run the facility.
And that's going to
be-- that's going
to increase your fixed cost.
So that happens in lumpy
fashion rather than variable
and scaling up [INAUDIBLE].
We have an additional
10 minutes.
And maybe it would
be a good opportunity
to discuss the first
assignment, which
I have not finished grading.
I'm sorry about that.
I hope to have that
back to you soon.
But we might as well go over it
and just discuss the solution.
So let me switch to that.
OK, so does everybody
remember the first assignment?
Or is that sort of back
in your [INAUDIBLE]----
you had some sample
data in a spreadsheet.
And you had to calculate--
the first question was,
calculate statistics
by direction.
So this is the spreadsheet, and
time of day, and running time.
This data was given to you.
And I like to use the
indirect function.
I don't know if people will know
it or not, but it's convenient.
So if you type the
range name in a cell,
then you can compute things as
a function of that range name.
And that's very convenient.
So I selected the
range B2 to B751.
And that corresponds
to all the data
on this, all the data
on this first sheet.
And then I did the same
for direction, too.
So therefore, when
I go to mean, I say,
equals average indirect of B4.
And I'm pointing the
mean to the range,
which is a variable in itself.
That's very neat.
So you can do that for
average mean, again,
min, max, and percentile,
and then fill to the right,
because you have a
different range here.
So it'll reflect that.
So it's a little trick.
So these are the statistics.
This was very straightforward.
Then Question 4, it starts
getting more at transportation
itself.
This requires some judgment.
So we're saying, what's
the running time?
What's the recovery time?
What's the half cycle time?
And what's the cycle time?
So running time
should be something
that happens typically,
because this is what
you publish on your schedule.
This is what's going to go
on your journey planner.
So people need to
know what to expect.
And therefore, running
time should be based
on the average or the median.
Of these statistics,
that you computed before,
these should be the
two that you use.
I usually prefer the
median, because the average
is affected by outliers and
by heavy tails on the right
quite a bit.
So I usually go for the
median, or the 50th percentile.
Recovery time-- so what
is recovery time for?
AUDIENCE: For making up--
well, first of all, so the
drivers can go to the bathroom
and things like
that [INAUDIBLE]----
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Sure, yeah.
AUDIENCE: --and then
second of all, to make up
for problems in the schedule.
So say I'm driving
out on this bus route.
And it takes me eight minutes
longer than I thought it would.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
I wouldn't characterize it
as a problem with the
schedule per se, but--
so the schedule is a
deterministic decision
about how long it will take you.
And the reality is
that the running time
is a stochastic variable.
It varies from run to run.
So you want to say--
you want to make
a claim about what
the typical running time is.
But then you have to have
some recovery time to account
for anything later than that.
And you recognize-- it's
a way of recognizing
that these running
times are stochastic.
So the half cycle
time is how much
time you budget for
the run, including
those late ones, right?
So I set that to a high
percentile, the 95th,
in this case.
The reading was
suggesting that you
could use 15% times the
average, or things like that.
When you have data, then
you should use the data.
So the technique of
taking an average
and multiplying
it by a percentage
is what the industry
typically does
when you don't have
automatically collected
data, when you
essentially send someone
out to drive behind the bus
or to do-- or a ride checker
to collect data on the bus.
And you do five, or
six, maybe 10 trips.
And then you get an average.
And that's not enough to
estimate your high percentiles,
because you probably didn't
see the high percentile
in those only 10 trips.
So therefore, you have to
rely on a different method.
And then you could
multiply by a percentage.
But if you have data, then
you should use the data.
And 10%, 15%, 20%,
whatever you use
might not be adequate
for a specific bus route.
So because you have
data, you can actually
measure how variable it is.
And therefore, high
percentile is a better choice.
95% is 1 in 20, right?
So if you think of there
being 20 weekdays in a month,
then you're saying,
well, about--
for the 8:00 trip, I expect
it to be late about once
in a month.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
it start out late.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
To start out late,
because it was-- yeah, for
there to be a knock on effect
on my next trip, essentially.
And for every other
time of the month,
I expect it to run smoothly.
So that's why 95 is a
typical choice here.
Lower numbers of percentiles
are common, especially
at high frequency service--
90, 85.
Question in the back, yeah?
AUDIENCE: So how do you
use the 95th percentile
for the recovery?
You said for the traffic--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Exactly, the half cycle
is the 95.
And the recovery time
is the difference
between the half
cycle and the typical.
So on your journey
planner, you only
put the running time,
but then between trips,
you add the recovery time.
And then the cycle time is the
sum of both half cycle times.
So that's pretty
straightforward.
Question 5 was,
how many vehicles
do you need to operate this?
And there is an
equation, which is maybe
the most important equation
in the whole course--
number of vehicles equals
cycle time divided by headway.
And you need to round up.
So cycle time is 84 minutes.
The headway we said
was 10 minutes.
So that's 84 divided by 10.
It's 8.4.
Round up, that's 9 vehicles.
OK, you need nine vehicles
to operate the bus route.
Question 6 asks you
to plot the times.
Hopefully you labeled your
axes and did everything
like you should.
And so here's time of day.
And here is running
times in direction one,
running times in direction two.
And we identify that not
all of these running times
come from the same
operating environment.
We can see that there are
some peaks and some off-peaks.
And uh oh, we just
calculated everything wrong,
because we mixed
up all the data.
And we shouldn't have.
So the question was,
what are these periods?
So AM peak going
from 7:00 to 9:00,
midday from 9:00 to 16:00,
and PM from 16:00 to 18:00.
And we assume a 24-hour format.
And now we have to
redo all the work.
We have to compute
the same statistics.
I've just changed the ranges and
copied the formulas from below,
and the fill to the right.
And we have all the statistics.
So that's great.
We repeat the calculation.
And we get the vehicle
requirement by period now.
We still need nine vehicles
in the AM and PM peaks,
but it turns out that
we only need seven
in the base, between peaks.
So that's great.
What's the cycle time?
The cycle time, once
you've calculated,
you can flip this equation.
I could have an entire
lecture on this equation.
Believe, it gets-- you
can flip it around.
And there is many ways of
interpreting this equation.
But if you solve
for c, cycle time
equals number of
vehicles times headway.
Now you don't round
any direction.
So once you've decided
what n is, then
you solve this equation for
c and revise your cycle time.
Because you rounded up, your
cycle time will have gone up.
And therefore, your recovery
time will have gone up.
The revised cycle time is
90 minutes, AM and PM peaks,
70 minutes off-peak.
And the recovery time
is the difference
between the typical running
time and the cycle time.
So then I asked, what if
you had done the mistake
of using all the data combined?
That means that you're
fine on AM and PM peaks,
but you would be excessively
provisioning resources
in the off-peak.
So your cycle time
was 90, because you
said it was nine vehicles.
And that recovery time would
be 30 minutes and a half,
which would be excessive.
AUDIENCE: It's fine if we
used the average instead
of the median, right?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
I prefer-- I think median
is a better choice,
but both are fine, especially
if you remove outliers
from the average.
And this data didn't
have outliers.
As you can see on
the graphs, it's
very suspiciously clean
data, and very precise,
places where the
period begins and ends.
The data you will
get for Assignment 3
does not look like that.
So all right, Question
9 said, now imagine
that this bus runs in a loop.
It only has one turn.
And I provide data.
We have data here for
that combined operation
of running inbound, then
outbound, then coming back.
We said we have a
headway of 7 minutes.
And we are running with a
fleet size of 10 vehicles.
How reliable is this service?
So we can compute
from the headway
the fleet size and cycle time
using this equation right here.
And we have 70 minutes.
And what we want to do then is,
from all these observations,
you can think of this as
some sort of probability
distribution.
We have some distribution
of running time.
This is probability density.
And this is running time.
And we said the
cycle time is 70.
So 70 will fall
somewhere around here it
turns out, if you look it up.
That's very close to 50%.
The way I computed it used
the spreadsheets solver,
you will see.
There are different
names for it.
So I said, calculate the
percentile of whatever
percentile I give you here.
So initially, I set it to--
I don't know, maybe
I set it to 95.
And it gave me the percentile.
This percentile is running
on the AM peak data,
or whatever it is
on spreadsheet 9.
And then I said, change
that percentile such
that the cell equals 70.
And it solved it.
And it gave 0.476 probability.
Is that reliable, yes or no?
No.
AUDIENCE: So what's that
probability refer to?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
That's the probability
that you can run in
70 minutes or less.
And therefore, you don't
cause delays on the next trip.
Your next trip
can begin on time.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Not reliable.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Not reliable, thank you--
OK, so Question 10 is
the challenge question.
And now we have two variables.
So now you have recovery.
You start at A. You go this way.
You reach B. You
do recovery there.
And then you run back.
So you have recovery
here and here.
And we're asking
about times here.
So we're saying,
what's the probability
with the same situation
of 7-minute headway
and a fleet size of 10 that
this trip can depart on time?
So for that-- there are
different approaches for this.
How many of you
tried the question?
And how many of you think
that they solved the question?
Most of you, OK.
AUDIENCE: Now with that answer.
GABRIEL
SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: So it's
actually not that
difficult. Essentially what
you have is a
situation where you
have different cases, right?
So if you run here, and you
reached terminal B early
before your half cycle
time is completed,
then you will recover at B until
you reach your half cycle time.
And in that case, the
only thing that matters
is the running time coming back.
But there is a case where
you run here and it's late.
And you depart immediately
from B. So for those cases,
you have to compute
the probability
that the combination of
running this way and that way
is less than 70.
So you have those two cases.
One way of doing that is to
take all the running times that
apply.
I think this said at AM peak.
So direction one is on column
A. There are 200 of these.
Direction two is on row one.
So I've done the transpose
and put it on a row.
And then, for each
of the cells, we
can compute the
combined running time.
So notice that, for the
first one, we're saying,
max of 35, which is
the half cycle time--
I decided here arbitrarily
to split the whole cycle
time of 70 minutes in half.
So I'm saying the half cycle
for the first run is 35 minutes.
And so the time of
departure from B
is going to be the maximum of
35 for cases where it was faster
than 35, or the running time
if it was longer than 35.
And then we add the running
time in the return direction.
So we combine these
two distributions--
that's called the convolution--
by adding all of these up.
And all of these
are possibilities.
All the combinations of these
observations are possibilities.
And then we repeat
the same thing.
So we say, let's
assume this is 50%.
And let's calculate
the percentile
on all the cells in that
matrix and ask the spreadsheet
to provide or solve for the
percentile that gives you 70.
And the answer is
0.418, so a little over.
Then there was an 11th question,
which is very important.
It's not a number question here.
But it said, there
is this person
who is watching these vehicles
recover at the terminal.
And this person is annoyed that
service is not frequent enough.
And these drivers
are wasting time.
And they're sitting
there not working.
And that person proposes
that you should run--
this person is an activist.
And they've gotten on the bus.
And they've measured
the average time.
And they say, you can
run this much faster.
You don't have to wait.
They're budgeting
for so much time,
so you should run
this at average
with average running times.
And it's your turn to
sort of argue back.
So hopefully you said that,
no, recovery time is important.
If you don't have recovery time,
then many trips will have--
will start late.
And if you're trying to take
your bus based on a schedule,
then it'll never
be there on time.
And that would be--
that would mean that you
have to wait a lot longer.
And it will be very
annoying for everyone.
So that's it for Assignment 1.
I hope you understood
all of this.
If you have questions,
let me know.
I will grade it and have it
back to you as soon as possible.